simplifica la expresión 12 x al cubo
llega al cubo
16 x a la cuarta y más 10 x dividido
entre 4 x muy bien hay varias formas de
pensar en esto lo primero que vamos a
hacer es separar esta división en tres
divisiones vale lo vamos a poner como 12
x al cubo y al cubo dividido entre 4 x 4
x + 16 x a la cuarta y hasta la cuarta
dividido entre 4 x 4 x + 10 x y dividido
entre 4 xy y hay varias formas de pensar
en cómo se llega a esta cosa
una vez pensar en que si tenemos una
división del estilo más b / c entonces
estudiar aquí es igual a en 13 + b / c
si simplemente estamos haciendo la suma
de fracciones verdad bueno le estamos
deshaciendo entonces se suman una forma
de pensar otra es que estamos
distribuyendo esta división en los tres
suman dos en este
en este y en este o bien una tercera
forma de pensarlo pero todas estas son
equivalentes es que estamos
multiplicando por 1 / 4x o sea 1 entre
4x y multiplicado sus mandos y estamos
usando la ley distributiva normal y está
la de la multiplicación para entonces
son formas equivalentes para llegar a
esta expresión y ya que tenemos esta
expresión simplemente hay que hacerla la
la división término a término dividir
entre el monome o 4x y vamos a ver
cuánto nos queda déjame tomar este color
azul entonces empezando con los números
en este primer término pues tenemos 12
entre 4 que es 3 este entre este estrés
entonces queda 3 luego vamos con la
equis un color verde entonces aquí
tenemos x al cubo y aquí tenemos x está
x es como un x a la 1
entonces usando leyes de los exponentes
tenemos que restar 3 menos uno y nos
queda 3
al cuadrado y finalmente tenemos ya la
variable de déjame ponerla con amarillo
y otra vez tenemos tenemos al cubo entre
y tres menos uno es dos entonces nos
queda
cuadrada muy bien entonces esto de aquí
es el primer término vamos a sumar le
vamos a sumarle lo que pasa con el
segundo término con el segundo terminó
con el segundo término 16 entre 4 es 4
x a la cuarta entre x pues cuatro menos
uno estrés nos queda 4x cúbica lo voy a
poner en color verde 4x cúbica x kubica
y luego qué pasa con la ya pues entre y
es uno es igual a uno podemos pensarlo
cómo llega la 1 entre la 11 menos 10
entonces llega a las cero pues también
da 1 aquí le podría poner por 1 pero
bueno no va a ser ninguna diferencia
entonces mejor ya nada más lo dejamos
así y a eso hay que sumarle lo que pase
aquí entonces misma idea en azul las
constantes diez entre cuatro y cinco
medios cinco medios y vamos a ver qué
sucede con los demás pues a ver x entre
x es 1 estos se cancelan y ya entregué
también es 1 entonces también se
cancelan y únicamente nos queda 5 medios
entonces la expresión simplificada es 3x
cuadrada y cuadrada más 4 x al cubo más
5 medios